>>> IN THE WAKE OF THE CHAUVIN
VERDICT, CBS NEWS IS TAKING A
CLOSER LOOK AT POLICING IN
AMERICA.
THIS YEAR POLICE HAVE KILLED AT
LEAST 319 PEOPLE IN THE U.S.,
ACCORDING TO A MONITORING GROUP.
BETWEEN 2013 AND 2020, 98% OF
KILLINGS BY POLICE DID NOT
RESULT IN CHARGES AGAINST
OFFICERS.
JEFF PEGUES SPOKE TO MIAMI'S
POLICE CHIEF ABOUT REFORM.
>> WHAT HAPPENED WAS A TRAVESTY,
WAS A CRIME, WAS UNJUSTIFIED.
>> Reporter: MIAMI'S NEW POLICE
CHIEF SAYS THE DEATH OF GEORGE
FLOYD IS A BLACK EYE ON THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT PROFESSION.
>> WOULD YOU SAY THAT POLICING
HAS BEEN ON TRIAL WITH DEREK
CHAUVIN?
>> I THINK ANY TIME THAT
SOMETHING LIKE MINNEAPOLIS AND
GEORGE FLOYD'S DEATH HAPPENS,
POLICING IS ON TRIAL.
THE ENTIRE PROFESSION IS ON
TRIAL.
>> Reporter: ACCORDING TO THE
COLLABORATIVE MAPPING POLICE
VIOLENCE, LAST YEAR BLACK PEOPLE
MADE UP 28% OF THOSE KILLED BY
POLICE, DESPITE ONLY BEING 13%
OF THE U.S. POPULATION.
>> NO JUSTICE, NO PEACE!
>> Reporter: FLOYD'S DEATH IN
MAY SPARKED PROTESTS AGAINST
POLICE VIOLENCE AROUND THE U.S.
AND AROUND THE WORLD.
TALK OF REFORM GAINED MOMENTUM.
BLACK MEN CONTINUED TO DIE AT
THE HANDS OF POLICE.
>> THIS IS A TASER.
THIS IS A TASER.
BUT NO, MY NEPHEW WAS KILLED
WITH THIS, A GLOCK.
>> Reporter: EARLIER THIS MONTH
20-YEAR-OLD DAUNTE WRIGHT WAS
SHOT DEAD IN MINNESOTA BY AN
OFFICER WHO OFFICIALS SAY MEANT
TO USE HER TASER, NOT HER GUN.
SHE'S BEEN CHARGED WITH
SECOND-DEGREE MANSLAUGHTER.
WRIGHT WAS KILLED JUST AROUND
TEN MILES FROM WHERE CHAUVIN WAS
ON TRIAL.
PRESIDENT BIDEN MADE A CAMPAIGN
PROMISE TO CREATE A COMMISSION
TO LOOK AT POLICE REFORM, BUT
LAST WEEK THE WHITE HOUSE SAID
THAT IT WOULD NOT MOVE FORWARD
AND INSTEAD THEY WOULD FOCUS ON
LEGISLATION.
>> WE HAVE NOT HAD A TRUE
COMMISSION ON POLICING IN THIS
COUNTRY SINCE DECADES AGO.
I THINK IT'S TIME FOR US TO HAVE
A COMMISSION TO TAKE A DEEP
DIVE, DEEP LOOK, EVIDENCE-BASED
APPROACH TO HOW WE IMAGINE
POLICING FOR THE NEXT COUPLE OF
HUNDRED YEARS.
>> Reporter: ARE YOU CALLING FOR
PRESIDENT BIDEN TO RECONSIDER
HIS DECISION NOT TO HAVE ANOTHER
COMMISSION?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> Reporter: UNDER INCREASED
CRITICISM AND SCRUTINY, POLICE
RECRUITING AND RETENTION IS ON
THE DECLINE.
POLICE UNIONS AND OFFICERS WILL
OFTEN POINT OUT THAT THEY HAVE A
HIGH INTENSITY JOB WHERE THEY
ARE SOMETIMES TASKED WITH MAKING
LIFE-OR-DEATH DECISIONS IN A
SPLIT SECOND.
>> WHERE DOES POLICING IN
AMERICA GO FROM HERE?
>> I THINK POLICING IN AMERICA
CONTINUES TO EVOLVE, CONTINUES
TO SEEK OPPORTUNITIES TO BE
BETTER, AND CONTINUES TO BUILD
TRUST, BUT ALSO POLICING IN
AMERICA NEEDS TO DO A BETTER JOB
OF HIGHLIGHTING THE MANY TIMES
THAT OUR POLICE OFFICERS GET IT
RIGHT IN VERY TENSE, DYNAMIC,
DANGEROUS SITUATIONS WHERE THERE
IS NO LOSS OF LIFE, THERE IS NO
USE OF FORCE OR THERE'S A
MINIMAL USE OF FORCE AND THE
SITUATION IS RESOLVED.
BECAUSE FOR EVERY ONE THAT'S
WRONG, THAT'S HORRIFIC, THAT IS
CRIMINAL, THERE ARE TENS OF
THOUSANDS WHERE WE GET IT RIGHT.
>> Reporter: ACEVEDA'S THOUGHTS
ON THESE ISSUES REALLY CARRY
WEIGHT IN WASHINGTON BECAUSE IN
ADDITION TO BEING THE CHIEF OF
POLICE IN MIAMI NOW, HE IS ALSO
THE PRESIDENT OF THE MAJOR CITY
CHIEFS ASSOCIATION.
AND HE BELIEVES THAT THIS
CHAUVIN VERDICT REALLY SHOWS
THAT JUSTICE WAS SERVED AND THAT
POLICE OFFICERS WHO BREAK THE
LAW ARE BEING HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
TONY.
>> YEAH, THERE IS A QUESTION,
THOUGH, OF HOW YOU DEFINE THE
LAW.
WITH 18,000 DIFFERENT POLICE
AGENCIES ALL ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY, YOU HAVE 18,000
DIFFERENT POTENTIAL DEFINITIONS
OF USE OF FORCE AND WHEN IT'S
APPROPRIATE.
IT'S GOOD THAT THERE'S A
NATIONAL CONVERSATION BEGINNING
SO THAT SOME STANDARDS C